okay mmm
what's up got my water with me this
morning yes yes how's it going everybody
oh man it is comics and coffee time
time for us to sit around and talk about
comic books and answer questions anyway
has everybody s morning coming along I'm
curious
ho girls mornings are cranking along
just fine I know -
oh man
well I think there's people outside
oh no sir good
huh such thing but anyway this t-shirt
is nice I appreciate it thank you very
much for complimenting me on my t-shirt
yeah I just woke up a little bit ago I
woke up maybe 45 minutes ago and then I
of course did some voting and then
hopped in the shower and Here I am now
so I never have coffee during
combination coffee you should know this
by now although I soaked all the comics
coffee because the name so cool
but um anyway what am i want my hearing
sound
I think it is just people outside now
I'm fine I just woke up a little bit ago
I'm not I'm not exhausted or anything
it's not on the verge of passing out but
yeah this just started so I'm going to
put on some music you know what it's
Christmastime I'm gonna listen to some
Christmastime jazz music by Christmas
time jazz music I mean Oh jazz music at
all I mean we're gonna listen to Paul
Oakenfold urban soundtracks Alice in
Wonderland because that was such a
really cool episode
it was such a cool concept okay
thank the comic gods my top two favorite
characters are alright I didn't see that
well crud oh yeah my all my issues
oh they becoming gods my top two
favorite characters all have issues
coming out the same day next week who
are your top two favorite characters I'm
curious long-haired hippy
I can't wait to hear about your story
about your lunch at school oh that girl
yeah man she beat the crap out of that
dude that was nuts you guys will talk
about Civil War
this is the date where I answer your
all's questions so feel free to ask away
you're a bigger comic fan than I am you
may very well be
do I like Doctor Who I've never actually
seen Doctor Who believe it or not I know
that's like a cardinal sin and geek
culture look you've never seen Doctor
Who what but I've never watched Doctor
Who so Rob what are your thoughts on
Jessica Jones will you be doing a review
video you'll actually find my review
video over at Rob explains oh man
and I read the new Hercules no I haven't
did they pay you to make those PSA
videos no that was just for fun
those PSD those PS any videos were just
something a little fun
I have fun making them and it looks like
people had fun watching so but those are
probably the only two I'll do I mean I
don't really see a reason to do any more
but but they were they were interested
you know I enjoy them so I mean I want
to get back more into characters and so
we're going to finish out a dark side
war and then let's go on on Super Sunday
show we're going to finish out dark side
war and then we're going to start doing
some more characters again because I
kind of miss doing characters so
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy was
really cool the books a lot more
interesting in the movie but well I
guess the books there's like seven or
eight books I think so
did I play Batman Arkham Knight yeah I
played Batman Arkham Knight it was okay
I got on the Xbox I thought it was an
alright game you know it wasn't the
greatest game ever but it was it was
pretty fun so no it's not in Halo this
is an e-cigarette what's your least
favorite comment to come out of the new
52 mm probably Wonder Woman I didn't
like her comic that much PSA stands for
public service announcement hash tag
team Iron Man I'm curious what side of
you guys on for Civil War are you guys
Iron Man are you guys Captain America am
I gonna continue the who's better series
yeah I probably can do that with another
episode we'll do well next one we'll
probably do like Superman and century
but uh but yeah we'll definitely do that
like once we finish Darkseid war guys um
that's probably the the last story arc
that we'll be doing until like maybe
Dark Knight Returns comes out and trade
but we'll be focusing on like characters
and comics so we'll be focusing on like
Wonder Woman
you know explained for the new 52
Aquaman explained for the new 52
you know maybe cyber war or something
like that we'll do characters we'll
probably even do like some DC obscure
characters but with Marvel you know
we'll do all-new all-different marvel
characters and we'll do more Marvel
comic characters things like that as a
tie-in to Civil War and so on so um mmm
Captain America forever
so many Captain America fans I feel like
like most people are Captain America
fans because freedom through the cycle
freedom yeah you stand with cap I I
stand with Ironman with regards to Civil
War like I I slide with Ironman on that
one I think he was right to be honest so
you are a legend sir will you do a video
on the authority there is very little
out there about them I live in over the
authority our team Ross team Walter
White bad is a way to go team Walter
White if Netflix came out with a series
to help expand the cosmic arena and the
MCU what will be the best candidate um
probably something to do with like Adam
warlock I'd say because Adam warlock was
pretty pretty awesome thoughts on gwyn
pool I don't think she's crap I think
it's a cool idea I'm curious to see
where they go with it
traitor
I think what am i one of my thoughts on
spider-man during civil war in the MCU I
have a feeling that spider-man is
probably going to be like have like a
cameo I don't think it's going to be
that the comics where he's literally the
middleman honestly I think the middleman
is going to be Bucky Barnes or Black
Panther Y Panther would make a good
middleman I think they're going to keep
that element of him because I think the
movie was too far along to rectify the
entire plot of the film in order to
include Peter Parker so I doubt Peter
Parker is going to be the middleman I
think it's going to be black panther
let's see yeah I saw that I saw that
write a post some people are saying they
think it's like Marvel oh the Kree so
you should do a video on resurrection
I've never heard of them a blue Marvel
show would be cool you're still be
holding you're still holding out for
Fantastic Four Darkseid is not
officially over Darkseid Wars not
officially over like act 1 so to speak
is officially over which is why we're
jumping into it now and hopefully like
it should be done and honestly it should
be done by the end of the week by like
Friday like it should be finished
because it's only for only four parts
and they're you know they're not double
size or anything so it should be done by
then
have you played Deadpool the video game
uh no I haven't played Deadpool the
video game thoughts on Dark Knight 3
book one actually I'm ready yet to be
honest now I know it's called master
race and I have that is how everybody
yet so how I making out making up pretty
well
doing pretty good it's tax time again so
that sucks going through all my taxes
and itemizing all that kind of stuffs
pain in the ass well it's not really a
hassle my state taxes are actually well
most of think that is really not that
difficult either
but the itemizing isn't the hard part
it's just hoping the IRS doesn't reject
any of it so I've read the spider-man
will have a bigger role than just a
cameo he's supposed to fight Captain
America ok yeah I don't know I mean I
know that in the comics spider-man was
the middle man he was literally like the
swing vote on registration and when he
left a lot of people I would he left the
side of Iron Man a lot of people left
with him in terms of his role in the
movie I doubt it'll be the same way I
think that's going to be Black Panther
because I think the movie was too far
along in terms of being written just
someone just replaced Black Panther with
spider-man but I don't know I mean you
know it's who knows what could happen I
made it yeah we won't know until the
movie comes out so let's see what are my
thoughts on flash season 2 so far flash
season 2 is amazing like it's I buy my
comic sort of local comic shop here in
town and digitally I buy Macaulay
ecology but no the flash season 2 is
really really good I don't consider
myself to be YouTube famous
but now flash season 2 is pretty awesome
I like the whole like using earth 2 as
an ongoing arc because they could do the
same thing with earth 3 and they can do
the same thing with you know different
different places elsewhere you know
different realities they can literally
just make up realities as they go along
that's a great thing about the
multiverse you know that's what DC was
doing in the comic so we're just making
up universes as they went along but it's
a cool concept you know I really like
what they're doing there um I don't know
did Jay Garrick go back to earth go back
to earth too
I don't know
my head because he's been added like a
bunch of episodes let's see did you get
that shirt from collector core yeah I
got it from collector Cory
thoughts on Jessica Jones Jessica Jones
was really really good I really enjoyed
it if you only had one to choose to see
Superman versus Batman or Star Wars or
Captain America I have to pick one
really that's a good question
Superman Batman Superman versus Batman
Captain America Civil War or Star Wars
Man
honestly I'd go see Star Wars I'd see
Star Wars first definitely okay I
thought he might have stayed okay as we
haven't seen him for a for a while and I
was like well I mean that's weird so we
know I've never watched Cowboy Bebop I
mean I know what it is and I know it was
big when I was younger but no I never I
never saw it I never saw it
see who do I think professor zoom is you
should go check out Benny's video about
that DX has a really good answer to that
question yeah I could read about the
rest well definitely start wars the
worst comic book villain there was a
villain from Marvel Comics from way back
in the day like and I don't know like in
the 1960s I think maybe 1970s he had the
ability to create force fields and he
was funding the x-men and something
happened and he lost the ability to
control his force field and suffocated
inside of his own force field like he
died because of his own powers
what's good Jaron Jaron Callum I think
is how you pronounce it I'm not sure if
thoughts on the dying print comic
industry I don't think it's dying by a
longshot
not at all I mean unless I mean I walk
into my comic shop and I see comics all
over the place so I don't figures any
indication that it's dying let's see
have I read angela queen of hell yeah
are you talking about the secret wars
times the secret war book because that
was actually pretty good um let's see
I'm actually vaping I'm not really
smoking but what do I think firestorm
Ronnie went I think he's actually dead
to be honest I mean they replace it with
a new character with a new version of
firestorm so I think he's gone so let's
see do you think do you think the Lord
that could be mr. Marvel and guardians
of the galaxy - oh you're talking about
Marvel yeah
I'm pretty sure that Marvel is star
Lloyd's father I'm at least I think
that's the case that they're making is
he's going to be star-lord father I'm
holding out hope for Adam warlock but I
could be wrong so
thoughts in the Gotham show um I watched
the first like season and then it just
wasn't really for me and so I just I
lost interest to stop watching it so had
Lee gotten really good like people are
saying it's getting really good I'm I
get back into it so which one of my
posters is my favorite um the one right
there on the middle Empire Strikes Back
I like that one the most but oddly
enough return to the Jedi is my favorite
of the Star Wars films so what's your
favorite all-new all-different title
from marvel definitely Deadpool I don't
have anything I have read all-new
all-different Deadpool but it's actually
really good it's actually really really
cool so let's see thoughts on the Black
Panthers who the Black Panther suit
looks amazing like a vibranium hybrid
like it looks amazing it's it's really
solid uh oh yeah David Tennant was super
creepy like he was really really weird
but it was done well I think they I
think they made him too human to be
honest I like just like him being just a
super evil guy but what they did with
him was still really good and David
Tennant was pretty amazing so I'm not at
all upset about it
oh the Ewoks were amazing yeah I'll
definitely read dr. 93 do you believe
James Gunn is trolling or think there's
actually a big undiscovered Easter egg
still in guardians of the galaxy I don't
think there's a big undiscovered Easter
egg I don't know how to go back and
watch it
let's see
yeah I'd watch the walking guy
definitely ten Isis Caesar the season
finale so I'm gonna like tomorrow is
going to be a review on the season
finale about the walking dead and what
direction I think it'll go in so do I
think Darrell's gonna die yeah I don't
think Darrell's going to die at the end
of this season but I think Darrell will
die in the show I think they're going to
kill him but I feel like if they did it
would drive down interest by fans it
would literally they would literally be
taking their own show so I don't know so
do I think they should play iron fist on
the Netflix oh who do I think should
play iron fist in the Netflix show um
there there's there's a guy you guys
should look him up there's a guy named
Daniel Bernhardt and he is he's really
really good at martial arts he did a lot
of camping movies like blood sport stuff
like that like he was never big in
bloodsport he did like plus four to
three I think even in bloodsport for he
was also one of the agents in the Matrix
films but he's he's actually a
legitimate martial artist and he's an
older guy but you know give him like
blonde hair and he could pull off a
pretty good Danny Rand I think he'd make
a great character the problem is he's
like a B or C less level actor so you
know I'm not really sure how that's
going to work but James Gunn said
there's one Easter egg nobody's found
yet in guardians of the galaxy
I don't know I'll have to go back and
come through it so what happened to the
old Silver Surfer video you had up early
on your channel that was a preview as a
trailer I mean I got rid of that that
was a trailer it was no need for it to
stay up there anymore so do I think
miles miles is gonna be the next
spider-man movie that they did well
Kevin Feige had actually done an
interview where he had talked about that
he had talked about Miles Morales being
spider-man and one of the things that he
said was when they got the rights to to
add spider-man to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it made sense to go with Peter
Parker and it does it makes perfect
sense to go with Peter Parker you know
because regardless of how good Myles
Wallace is as spider-man Peter Parker's
are recognizable spider-man and so if
you're going to bring in people to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe you know your
comments are posting fun if you're going
to bring in Peter Parker to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it makes sense to
bring in I guess bring in spider-man
make sense to bring in Peter Parker and
then segue into my house Bareilles later
on that makes more sense to me so I'm
not one of those people who's upset
because Miles Morales is not the Peter
Parker or not this part of my network
getting I'm fine with that yeah so um
Rob makes the souls of the week but the
I'm baby the souls of my comment my
vanquished foes
do I prefer daredevil or Jessica Jones
Jessica Jones actually it's pretty
awesome
let's see
well defenders end up an infinity war I
have no idea I'm hoping I'm hoping that
infinity war turns out to be this just
massive undertaking like this this huge
inclusion of all these different
superheroes
I'm really hoping that's the case it
might not be but I'm hoping that it is
oh let's see
if the entire Marvel or DC universe
could be rewritten by one writer who
would you pick Geoff Johns and if Geoff
Johns couldn't do it then Jonathan Ahmed
let's see do you want MC you to follow
civil wars any in comics ah where
Captain America gives up yeah because
that was a really important moment for
Captain America to quit you know for
Captain America to basically walk away
and to say like we're not fighting for
the people anymore we're fighting for
the sake of fighting that was that was I
mean it was the most logical conclusion
you could draw now it was written that
way explicitly in order to simply bring
it into the story I mean there was
there's really no deeper meaning there
there's really no philosophical you know
hidden meaning behind why the ending was
the way it was you know it was just
literally Marvel saying well we got to
end this somehow and so Mark Miller just
ended it that way but you know the fact
remains that the way it was done I
thought was was was really cool you know
um the idea of Captain America somewhere
just giving up plus it's at the stage
were scared to be killed later on and
that's what that's what would happen in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is that
they would like capture him but some way
like he would have to effectively lose
the fight so ya know kid flash as far as
I understand it will not up here on the
flash season 2 will just get like Wally
West they're just going to introduce
Wally West so let's see
Rob what do you think of Superman
American alien Superman American alien
is so good max landis like man his
writing is amazing like issue number one
was incredible and I want to do those
videos like I want to do videos on those
stories oh yeah I'm definitely doing my
dream job this is amazing but well I
guess I guess I'd be like voice work
like doing like narrating for a living
will be my dream job but this is
definitely pretty amazing um no like
like super an American alien is
fantastic such a great series of stories
I'm going to looking forward to it
because apparently each one is supposed
to be like a section of his life like we
were talking about veteran weekly pull
and I didn't know how it was supposed to
go and I think either sell or Joel said
it was basically gonna be like different
sections of his life you know um how old
am i I'm 31 years old what if the ending
of Civil War includes Thanos versus the
Avengers I don't think that'll happen no
I don't think it'll happen at all let's
see do I think zoom is earth to Wally
West that would be wild if he was earth
to Wally West uh that'd be pretty crazy
um let's see Rob what are your thoughts
on the Star Wars comics they're actually
written really well um I really enjoyed
what Jason Aaron is doing so far but for
whatever reason I don't know if it's
just a lack of interest I don't know if
it's because you know people just don't
care but Star Wars videos just never do
well on the comics explain like it's
it's strange but they do pretty well on
Rob explains you know so I've basically
kept the Star Wars videos over there but
yes it's kind of wild the thoughts on
Deadpool kills more universe great story
also story um let's see
ah Rob the narrator I would watch that
you'd watch that okay uh let's see
walk user um who is your favorite old Oh
what's your favorite old superhero
cartoon um definitely extra in the
animated series like that was during my
time like I really enjoyed exper the
animated series it was it was pretty
awesome
yeah played Star Wars Battlefront
it wasn't bad at all it was a little
repetitive it was pretty basic but the
simplicity of the game I think is what
makes it so fun that it's a no frills
game like there's not all kinds of stuff
tied into it you know it doesn't feel
like it's moving a million miles a
minute it's actually a pretty fun game
so I might play some battlefront later
on to later on today actually my player
hearing a little bit as we get done with
this play that for a couple hours and
then work on our Dark Star War video for
tomorrow let's see do you like where
Scott Snyder's going with Batman with
Gordon doing robot Batman
um it's okay um I like that he was
experimenting um I like that he was he
was kind of changing things up a little
bit and and really just like removing
Bruce Wayne to the picture that kind of
experimentation I think is always a good
idea it never hurts to say like what
would happen if we got rid of Batman got
rid of Bruce Wayne is Batman and
replaced it with somebody else it
creates for actually some pretty
compelling stories the problem is you
know I I'm so used to Bruce Wayne as
Batman that is difficult to imagine
someone else being Batman and I feel
like if he kept Jim Gordon on long
enough then I would get usage important
and then they would get rid of Jim
Gordon and bring back Bruce Wayne and so
I think them you know bringing Bruce
back makes sense you know it makes the
most sense to me so I'm playing on ps4
ah Saints Row 3 I haven't played 200
Saints Row 3 yeah yeah Saints Row 3 was
awesome like yeah that game was pretty
amazing
it was an over-the-top ridiculous GTA 5
and that's what made it so cool so
now I'm not gonna live street battle
from your so behind on comic so that's
my channel's force to get you caught up
have I seen Gotham and if so okay yeah
we already talked about Gotham like I
said you know I I saw the first season
lost interest in it and really haven't
watched it since when people of been
saying it's really good and some people
say it's really good then I guess it's
worth checking out
so getting back into again out of all
the new Dark Side War gods who's your
favorite bad goddamn god Green Lantern
God Lantern God Superman or or the flash
well Batman to be honest like I like an
all-knowing Batman like it fits his
character perfectly you know the Batman
knows everything um that is a cool
concept it's weird to see him on the
Mobius chair but it's a cool concept
what I do reaction videos probably not I
did one or two of those and I think it
was fun just to kind of do in passing
but that's that's not something that I'd
make a regular thing I don't think plus
the issue that you went into is you know
a lot of the contents copyrighted and
what would happen is if I could do like
like I want to do a reaction video on
the trailer for dead for what the issue
is that it was copyrighted and sure that
means I'm an Eevee or a twenty
microphone sure it means that the video
could be uploaded but it also means that
that would draw the attention of Fox and
they could give you a copyright strike
which could definitely cause problems on
my channel so if you could give one
Marvel character a Green Lantern ring
who would it be
ooh that's a good question if I could
give a Marvel character a Green Lantern
ring
I probably give it to Reed Richards I
think he'd be the most reasonable
character to get a Green Lantern ring
nod I'd probably definitely give it to
Reed Richards all right so here's my
question for you guys
um are not I don't know that'll have
klatch answer um if you guys could give
it an infinity stone to a DC character
who would you give it to
like what infinity so would you give it
to let's see how many minutes are we in
um I don't know we're about 26 minutes
in about halfway through ah let's see
do you prefer to buy issues trade
paperback or digital um if it's a story
that I know I'm going to enjoy I buy the
trade if it's a story that I'm not sure
about I'll buy the first few issues and
then if I really like it then I'll just
find the trade I'll just buy the rest of
the issues to be honest but let's see
you give a you give an infinity stone to
to Batman Wow you give Batman the mind
Jim Wow
so many people say they'd given infinity
stone to Batman the soul stone to
Superman all right well here's a
question for you guys why are you guys
such huge Batman fans and I'm asking
that seriously I'm not together be
sarcastic I'm nice enough seriously like
well you guys had Shuja Batman fans like
what is it about Batman that you guys
like I guess is a better way to answer
to ask that question flash would the
power gym would be unstoppable that
would be nuts
daredevil would get the Green Lantern
ring he's the man without fear that is
true power Jim tonight wing time Jim -
the flash is all-new all-different
marvel worth reading
definitely all-new all-different marvel
is definitely worth reading um the
problem with all-new all-different
marvel is that a lot of it's not that
new and not that different Deadpool for
example comes out of the previous run of
Deadpool you know all-new all-different
Deadpool comes out of the previous run
and so there are elements when we make
our video on all-new all-different
Deadpool like I'll let you guys know
I'll tell you guys how it ties into his
continuity prior to Secret Wars because
it does and it's you know it's really
kind of weird so
he represents the common man while
suberin doesn't he's amazing because his
parents died sue ran too powerful
there's no way you can relate to him we
don't know how Deadpool came back we
haven't got an answer to that question
that's during that eight month window
where stuff happened and everything
reset apparently sent along those lines
so
have you given up seeker wars like at
least six years now I mean I'm still
doing videos on Super Wars I mean
honestly I'm not reading them until I
get until I make the video but I'm not
going out to the store and reading it as
soon as I get it like I get it and it
kind of sits there for a while until I
make the video but um let's see Joker
gets the reality Jim yeah people are
still answering that's nuts
imagine rune King Thor with a fully
composed for yeah that'd be stupid
powerful Hugh Jackman is one of the
fourth Horseman that's what I'm kind of
curious about I haven't read enough
about x-men apocalypse do we know who
the fourth horsemen are going to be like
we know who those horsemen are going to
be I'm kind of curious
the best origin in my opinion this
century what you juice am I using I'm
using a captain Krunk which is actually
really really good can I do a video on
lord beerus god of destruction um yeah
that's going to be on Rob explains let's
see
imagine John Cena gets the Infinity
Gauntlet John Cena what do I get my
poster flames those came with the
posters let's see why has a Batman
gotten rid of krama Gotham because then
you'd be out of a job
there'd be no reason for him to exist
anymore you love death in the family
yeah definitely family is really good
dozens of families a classic story death
of the family a good story too
so what headset am i using these are AKG
headphones but I actually got a set of a
P piece sevens I think from Bowers &
Wilkins those are really good
I would give Batman the mind gym
Superman the soul Jam one of them in the
power gym Darkseid the reality gym flash
the time gym Lex Luthor the space gym
Lex Luthor with a spaceship would be
really cool well I do a video on Green
Lantern Godhead and the new gods um I'm
a I mean right now we're getting into
new gods and listen let's talk about
this for a second guys so for those of
you guys who were reading Darkseid war
and we'll talk about this during our
video on Darkseid work those were guys
who were reading Darkseid war and you
find yourself confused about the new
gods you find yourself confused about
Darkseid um I'm not interested in
playing a p7s or headphones I'm not
interested playing counter-strike oh um
you know Darth the new gods are weird
concept so so the way it originally
happened was when Jack Kirby went
tomorrow I went to DC created the fourth
world and the fourth world was the new
gods that was dark side that was high
father that was mr. miracle who would
become mr. miracle scott-free you know
it was it was all that stuff created and
it was designed to be a separate
continuity was designed to be completely
isolated from Marvel Comics or from DC
Comics well the problem was there was
creative differences and Jack Kirby left
before the Fourth World was finished and
he went back to Marvel and so what DC
did is they took what had been created
or at least the aspects they liked about
what had been created and they rolled it
over into the DC continuity and so when
you have like the huge DC multiverse you
know you have you know all these
different universes and all the
different all the different kinds of
stuff
you only have one apocalypse you only
have one new Genesis you only have one
Darkseid one highfather one mr. miracle
you know and so they're they're
multiversal I guess yeah multiversal
constructs they are there's only one of
them in the entire multiverse and so
what geoff johns is doing is he's taking
a lot of the old stuff from you know
from the new gods as it existed the way
was written by Jack Kirby and he's
literally rewriting it for the new 52
and so you know that's why I have a
video
on the new 52 so I have new video on a I
haven't video on new gods and darkside
but what we're going to do with our
video on darkside war is we're going to
rehash a lot of that stuff because a lot
of people may not have seen that video a
lot of people may not be interested in
watching that video
they may not know it's there and so you
know if we're going to be doing darkside
war it makes sense to run over that
stuff again you know and so the first
video is going to be a pretty lengthy
video and we're going to go through and
basically run over you know all that so
we're going to talk about dark side in
the new gods and all reference people to
that video you know if they want to get
a more comprehensive explanation because
there's no point in doing you know an
hour-long video with twenty minutes on
dark side of the new gods and 20 minutes
on scot-free mr. miracle and then you
know 20 minutes on on issue number one
that's how long it turns out to be you
know so you know that that's its that's
what we're gonna do basically is make
sense of all that stuff so um let's see
why did Jack Kirby leave Marvel in the
first place because of creative
differences he felt like it wasn't being
appreciated and so he left Marvel went
to DC and then when he was a DC you felt
like he wasn't being appreciated and at
the end of the day it was a simple you
know case of the devil you know is
better than the devil you don't know and
so he just went back to Marvel so um hey
Rob I have a question can you explain
how Iron Man got his arc reactor back in
the end of Iron Man 3 I remember he
threw it in the seal we just kind of
left to assume that he had one sitting
around that he I don't know that he just
created one I don't know the answer to
that question I'm hoping the answer that
but at this point we don't know there's
been no information
you know forthcoming on you know
connecting Iron Man at the end of Iron
Man 3 to the current current events I
mean he had it removed and all that kind
of stuff and and if you look you know
though his armors designed differently
and so we're just kind of left to assume
that the arc reactor technology wasn't
necessary anymore force chest you know
because of the surgery that he had done
and had those
that those pieces of shrapnel removed
and he says makes me got a gaping hole
his chest but um I'm not really sure
where they're gonna go with that I'm not
sure what they're going to do with that
so no Jack Kirby passed away a while ago
um let's see do I feel the DC should
have made a blackest night brightest a
movie that actually wouldn't been a bad
idea um you know the problem with that
is there'd be a lot of backstory that
needs to be explained you know a lot of
explanation that needs to show up about
the different Green Lantern cores and
all that kind of stuff and that makes it
a little more complicated so no I don't
read Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
although apparently I've heard it's
pretty amazing and I need to so is there
any essential reading before dark side
war not really um
but any of the stuff that you need to
know before getting into darkside war
you'll find on my channel like you could
literally just go back and watch my
video on dark side of the new gods and
then jump into darkside war and darkside
works pretty much standalone you could
read you know Justice League issues one
through five and that will cover a lot
of that stuff but you know that's
basically just them fighting Darkseid
for the first time it's really hid so
it's really not necessary to be honest
in fact you know when geoff johns does
Darkseid war ii he references it he
referenced Justice League issues one
through six but basically like clears it
up you know and makes it so you don't
need to go back and read those if you
don't want to so um let's see what
happened to pepper in the MCU we assume
or at least I assume that she left that
she just weakly walked away from Sarg
industries I don't know let's see
not overly read Stephen King my
PlayStation Network handle is Marvel
explained you stand with your feet which
trailer do you like best Batman vs
Superman or Civil War civil war
definitely but at the end of the day I
think when it comes down to it Batman
and vs Superman will probably sell more
because it's two iconic characters
fighting one another so whatever
happened a long shot in the comics and
do I think a mojo universe I don't think
they'll do an illusion universe and I
have no idea what happened a long shot
the copies I stopped reading him 15 20
years ago let's see who would I give a
yellow lantern ring to
I'd give a yellow lantern ring to
spider-man I think it'd be cool um let's
see or I give a yellow lamp terrain to
this century do i light the earth one
books I actually haven't read those okay
so here's my here's the question I might
ask you guys are the earth one books
good because I was thinking about this
the other day when I was going through
best fly and I was you know it was
periscoping and I saw those those comics
the best I was selling which is weird
they had a great big huge thing and one
of them was like Superman earth one are
the earth one books good
like I'm I've heard they're pretty good
but I don't I don't know I'm curious you
give one to kingpin even civil war is a
fight between iconic heritage yeah it is
but those characters are nearly as
iconic as Batman and Superman I mean
there's really no denying that like
Batman and Superman are the two most
iconic characters and comic books
everyone knows who they are
you know everyone everywhere knows who
they are not nearly as many people know
who Bucky Barnes is or Black Panther you
know super I guess I Captain America
more people know who he is but you know
like it's definitely you know it's
definitely Batman Superman in terms of
popularity so
yes they are amazing earth-1 books are
good f1 books are fantastic worth it man
they're freakin great Rob would what
would your ideal team up between one
Marvel character one DC character and
one Image Comics character ooh the
century Batman and spawn would be an
awesome team up I think I mean those are
the first three that came to mind
so like I'd definitely take those
Hulk would probably shatter the red ring
and it would kill Bruce Hulk would
probably shatter the red ring like you
would try to attach itself to him and he
would just grab it and smash it that
would be cool they really need to do
that like they need to do a crossover
between Marvel and DC like we're like
like a Green Lantern Marvel crossover
and like the Green Lantern Corps in like
the different the different Lantern
cores invade Marvel Comics like that
would be cool how many the guys would
read that if the Lantern cores invaded
Marvel Comics and it was literally just
like you know it was just this great big
huge crossover and you had like Batman
Superman yadda yadda yadda but all the
lantern cores showed up in the Marvel
and Marvel Comics like how cool would
that be
so I actually haven't read sex criminals
I've heard it's good but I probably
won't do a video on that on my channel
just because it's not very
family-friendly so Austrian ski wrote it
Straczynski is such a good writer I
didn't realize he wrote Superman earth-1
do I feel the NuVision comic is
interesting or just weird no I think
it's really interesting I think it's
pretty solid um I read it in trade I
would definitely 100%
I would totally read that yeah I think
it'd be pretty awesome
ya know they've crossed over but they
haven't had like the Lantern cores
crossing over like they haven't done a
crossover since Geoff Johns reboot of
the Green Lantern series so like and the
really cool thing is if they did that if
they had like all the lantern cores show
up on in the Marvel Universe you could
just like give you could have Lantern
rings going to different people like
that would be that would be a really
cool scene and the thing where like the
Red Lantern ring you know like shows up
and tries to attack the Red Hulk
any little just like catches it midair
and like crushes the ring and like into
dust and
Syd he's like I don't need that there
was something like that it can be pretty
awesome I appreciate it I got this shirt
from a collector cord and it's actually
really coupled to is like 100% cotton so
it's really soft
would you read a book where a hero is
called the hype maybe I'd be a little
defeated is Jeff John's a good rider
definitely Jeff Jones is a fantastic
writer uh can a babe uh lift Thor's
hammer like a baby uh I don't know
that's a good question I don't know I
mean they're devoid of good or evil
they're simple just they just exist do
they have no intention so I'd say
probably not because they you know
they're not so probably not because I'd
like to think I mean that's the problem
with the enchantment is it so open you
know it's you know whosoever holds us or
yeah whosoever finds a 10 or whatever it
is if he be worthy shall possess the
power of Thor and my life can cure
cancer but um it's so open-ended like
you could interpret it different ways
you know are they battle forged like
like for you know are they do they have
good intent you know babies don't have a
Tim baby just exist it's not until they
become knowledgeable educated that they
they gain intent you know before they
they experience the world do they gain
intent so I don't know I'd say probably
not but yeah the hype is not worth I've
what are your thoughts on Thor on the
Thor and Hulk team up and Ragnarok I
actually think it's a really really cool
idea Thor and Hulk teaming up is an
awesome concept I'm actually really
excited to see what they do with it I
mean it'll just be for fighting on
behalf of I guess uh Hulk fighting on
behalf of Thor but I'm still I'm still
hyped to see what happens I'll
definitely check out the earth 1 Series
you know if you guys say it's really
good I'll definitely check out everyone
so I assume or stand alone like they're
isolated they don't really tie into
continuity is that the case like you do
the earth 1 stories not tie into
continuity we'll look that up real quick
ah original graphic novel series okay so
their original graphic novels they're
not tied into continuity okay cool
those are those are some of my favorite
stories are the ones that don't tie into
continuity the ones that are isolated so
Dan Robert you have a radio voice I
appreciate that I I do the best I can
but the voice that I have to make it
sound as attractive as possible but it
takes a lot of editing takes a lot of
time and it can be very time consuming
to make my voices awesome as it is
there's a big difference between
innocence and worthiness that is true is
ultimate DC okay cool that's cool
let's see Rob a team-up between Lex
Luthor Doctor Doom and dr. zero that's
the weird team-up dr. zero is what
strikes me as a weirdness I mean it's
cool you know but it's an interesting
one um let's see earth one Teen Titans
is phenomenal so was it like a whole
line of just earth 1 titles because we
might we might start doing those I mean
let's see earth 1
let's see
why do i vape with a dehumidifier wow
there's Superman earth 1 OS M 2 volume 3
Batman earth 1 Teen Titans earth 1 1 one
earth one Aquaman the flash Wow huh I'll
definitely check those out then yeah I
got my ticket for Star Wars definitely I
wouldn't actually got my ticket when
they first released him when they first
released the tickets and there were only
two available in the theater I was like
that's nuts so I want to see it by
myself but I'm pretty sure made a bunch
of friends I'll get together and go see
you later on - oh god a green light
green lantern Dragon Ball crossover
would that not be amazing like imagine
Goku with like a yellow lantern not
really go through like Vegeta with the
yellow Lantern ring like oh my god
that'd be amazing or like with a red
light oh god Vegeta with a Red Lantern
ring like that would be amazing
how many of you guys would go see like I
would read like a Green Lantern Dragon
Ball Z crossover I'd read the heck out
of that like definitely
let's see earth one Superman vol 1 is
where they got Man of Steel for okay huh
Black Panther is in the trailer looks
like he fell off a motorcycle after
being the bad guy in an Evel Knievel
strap I don't think so he looks awesome
I think he looks really good
do I have to kill myself in order to get
robbed to watch preserve or at least the
OVA that's that's a crazy sentiment
that's of course not but I won't watch
it so um that would be awesome I would
black ass night dragon ball let's see I
have Jerry Conway is doing a need for a
DC question Netflix series I don't know
if I'd really watch it the only way I'd
watch is if it had like a noir feel to
it if it felt like like Blade Runner
then I'd probably watch that but if it
didn't you know I probably wouldn't they
let's see
toy animation of DBZ have a good
relationship with DC do they really huh
that is crazy man my kim teacher got
tickets already - yeah
ah let's see
excited for chains me ninja turtles bad
all they are doing a crossover aren't
there I'll probably do a video on that a
black lantern Goku that'd be pretty wild
kill Goku off and then bring it back as
a black lantern I mean it'd be worth it
like I'd what I'd check that out did
flash shovel where a lantern ring yes he
will enter ring on a couple of occasions
um he wore a blue lantern ring I think
during was it during injustice guys that
he wore blue anten ring and then um he
was I think it was another Lantern at
one point I think I don't suppose when
the chat guys like what what lantern
rings did the flash ever have because
I'm not going to swear - swear to that
but I thought he may have one electrode
ring at some point oh I definitely watch
a Silver Surfer movie definitely let's
see is the definitive Superman series /
no but it's actually being transformed
into something else and you guys will
find out soon Kentucky Wildcats football
does suck yeah I'm not gonna sing for
you guys
can you explain guillotine I don't know
who gay teen is let's see blue lantern
flash
yeah blackest night that's what it was
like ass night
the blue and the green okay the blue
ring mr. Satan gets an ordering he gets
the white Lantern ring of life ah let's
see the flash had a blue and white
during darkest night and brightest day
in blackest night and brightest oh yeah
blue and black okay that's not Batman
Europa I already get Kid Buu with the
lantern II would be nuts
pithy Aretha Franklin ring it makes you
Jesus at singing it makes you an
incredible singer Oh see blue looks like
blue is all okay huh I don't know Red
Lanterns Super Girl yeah that looked
really cool well I do old man Logan
Secret Wars I'm actually debating on
that I'm not sure if I'm going to I may
or may not it's weird
I don't know ah see do you think the
Punisher will get his own Netflix show I
hope so like I really want the Punisher
to get his own Netflix show like I'm I'd
really enjoy doing that oops like I
think it'd be pretty awesome
I knocked over my bottle of e-cigarette
stuff good thing I had my like app on it
would have gone all over the place um a
lightsaber powered by an infinity stone
oh my god like whip it out like like
activate the whip and I activate the
lightsaber than ultra-reality Billy
pretty awesome um alright guys we're
going to wrap this episode of how much
to coffee up and running for about an
hour or so which is par for the course
when it comes to this so I'm going to
bounce off here but I'm definitely gonna
check out earth 1 I appreciate the
suggestions guys I'm glad you guys you
know do that in there because I hadn't
really thought about it before but I'll
definitely check out earth 1 it sounds
like it's an incredible story like it
sounds like it's really cool and and yes
so anyway we're going to wrap this up
for those of you guys who were
interested in playing battlefront semi a
a message on Marvel explained on a
Playstation on the ps4 and I'm going to
go grab some breakfast and I guess make
some breakfast and then yeah I'm down to
play so I'll probably be on here and the
next half an hour or so and yeah so I'll
catch you guys later peace